what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg and John here today
we are going to wrap up The Witcher
season three part one uh with episode
four and five today putting it all in
one video John how are you Tess I am so
ready for this mid-season final nice
thanks nice I say yes refer to that man
ooh ladies and gentlemen uh toss a coin
to that like button if you've been
enjoying the Witcher season three or
just to show support for the cavil and
uh secondly thank you to all who have
joined us at our patreon page
full-length and watch the longest single
with your own copy of which are
available for super sexy rejects over
there also cover several things
exclusively reaction Heights and watch
songs included uh we did shoot episode
four on a separate day so uh we're gonna
look a little different for for that but
we'll be looking like this one once we
get to episode five because we did not
prepare in advance to trick you let's
get to it
thank you
[Music]
oh
and then he says your voice cracks never
seen you sleep past Dawn waking him up
himself I have a mission for you and
then you clean up your mess that is all
the proof I need to know that you were
ready can I have a coffee first
Francesca will not be an easy target are
you having doubts fringella what became
of her she's dead and you were here
lucky you we must set our differences
aside to create a stronghold rodania
acts in their own interests the posture
yes understands intimately a lot of
people understand that intimately if we
are to unite the continent no more
division no more secrets we can all be
our best selves live our best lives no
cap that little speech is turning this
turns around
like a fungus grows on you and you're
the toe my friend so now we have to go
to aratuza I thought you said it wasn't
safe because of what you saw in the
castle why don't you want to go there a
bunch of Diva [__]
because it's filled with Tatty women who
gossip and get sloppy drunk and I said
some things Deanna for that I regret
she'll forgive you she'll write you many
letters invitations are going out across
the continent we expect responses within
the day meeting of the eratusa origami
Club you know for someone who disdains
politics you do excel at it this is what
it takes to keep us all safe then it's
worth it the also already agreed to the
conclave you can drop the growth like
now never Elizabeth her room is empty I
told the novices to relocate to loxia
for the conclave there was blood what if
she's hurt well then we need to get less
clumsy novices they don't seem concerned
at all by then geralt is bringing Siri
everything
yeah you aren't traumatized At All by
what Siri did I've been tracking all the
novices who've gone missing this year
yeah they were three or four more years
they couldn't hack it I know these
feels like something
check the eel pool
it's a coincidence what are you thinking
they're being used to pretend to be Siri
I think they've been taken by force book
monoliths it holds a key to traveling
between spheres what if the person who's
kidnapping those girls is planning to
use the book to banish them or save them
themselves
then one problem solved
King curries are slow riding all the way
back to go as well and would take longer
besides the passage has already been
arranged beautiful oh damn where'd they
shoot this why are you not on board yet
the ferrymen won't cross he's convinced
there's a monster in the water ooh yes I
doubt it's anything that dangerous maybe
we've been focusing so much on my magic
but what about my hunting skills my
ability to protect myself there's a
smile if we kill your monster we accept
that as payment for the passage you've
got yourself a deal and the Astro is
just gonna chill while they do this run
up in the Scarborough the tower on than
it came down on the ground they
real powerful what do they want here
they're lucky for you
no survivors not even the hobbits this
guy's right on the money that's best to
leave fortune telling to the soothsayers
like a peaceful day to me peaceful day
you brought these guys on your ship in
order to kill something
an acapella group yes
rival bards to say I will always protect
you but every time you leave a mess
behind she's the one who cleans it up if
you're here to use her and abandon her
again tell me now I'll help you
if I tried she knows me at my core that
softly snort makes me wonder if you
believe her for what it's worth I'm
happy to see the person she's become
around you it's good I just needed to
get laid
the procession has started and your
portal awaits I brought you your
mustache for a camouflage
somebody want definitive answers before
we crash the brotherhood's party even
Kingdom event is proposing an alliance
soon all the northern kingdoms will be
fighting at upperhast
dastardly was so close to Unity I
suspect it's an issue skin is Roth and
covered in spikes difficult to penetrate
except for a tender patch on the top of
its skull
this fight if we're to lure it into
proximity we can strike from above
without any harm or damage to the ferry
or anyone on board or it's just a shark
it's a Meg I was personally requested by
the witch Sabrina gloversik should Myers
both my instruments there's two penises
it's a natural Oddity this man we are
gathered here today to honor the memory
of my beloved Queen Hedwig they put
their head just on the body
I was expecting to say to send a liaison
for your little party I've known it was
you I would if I approved this place you
guys suck at the whisper again you
should go outside I came here
go on I'm listening and to assure you
that the incident of the Abbey was
misguided I also wanted to invite
Philippa as an honored guest at the
conclave of Mages monarchs need more
reliable protection I insist she attend
there we go Jennifer yeser and dextra
and radovid I won't take no for an
answer how rad of it's gonna go this has
got interesting and the whole Kingdom
goes
and so depressed me
[Music]
I love love monster kill them
song about one and they definitely come
swim I'm gonna swallow you up I just
learn everything I know from songs let's
keep our enemies close I am beloved by
all and have no enemies there it is
oh oh he lives
oh good the Oscar's gonna fight yeah
that is an astronaut okay
[Music]
got this Siri
oh the family that slays together
you're the gears
oh
[Music]
I am Siri
Queen hear me roar
the answer never easy
really you adapted at every turn that
took 45 seconds yes a lot easier than it
was made out to be he left these monster
hunts all season have been incredibly
short because the real monster is
political gain
wow Jennifer
that's not the real geralt where's Siri
we don't have much time I thought you
was with you what happened no we're in a
Flash Forward
sweet
nope it's an illusion
[Music]
I was attacked an illusion I need to
talk to you no something is going on
here something sinister that's right to
say I can't know you need to be careful
who you can trust
I was not a suspicious look on your face
whoa what insane visual effects Magic
movie Magic bringing Siri
why is neither good
it's not what I meant
just tell her and do you know when I was
most dangerous suppressed
and alone that will not happen to her
not as long as I'm around nothing's
gonna harm you
was real
in that castle I found young women who
are a part of some horrific experiment
only one of them survived they've
implanted your memories whoever else is
working for their ultimate plan is to
manipulate you it's like a subplot in
Days of Our Lives
[Laughter]
we have to protect more of these women
from getting hurt and find the majors
behind this yeah where's that faceless
lady she's not faceless that's why we
have to go to aratuta see when you're
honest
you get results leaves to break throughs
[Music]
chug chug chug chug chug
what do you mean you can't get any more
oil for a fortnight every bloody Mage in
the World's Gonna Be there and you know
that off drink why don't I
started on Mage wait no I'm hearing that
boats are going missing up and down the
western coast war is in the air greggle
you say boats
you guys need to be observing you're
working a bar I just wanted to let you
know that I'm I'm happy to do the other
very important job excellent
you'll be looking after Siri tonight
what I mean it was a fan pen come on
let him have this
let's never do that again
you guys are so functional you are you
fed her to the magical Lions then I
trusted you
making this all up
that's also the role of poetry
funny I wonder how she learned such
complete not a disregard for authority
I forgive you
your various foolish words indeed for
your socking and posing trying worthy of
a man I forgive you for being a Wily
witch who rarely listens and even more
rarely admits to being wrong
let's never do that again
but the whole rest of the show to
proceed like this
oh every time
truly is a delight taking your course
yeah I'm sure you do oh now you count
money I'm sorry ahead with me
instead of at the party oh I'm not you
don't have to prove what you're going to
be in the future let's be here now I
think you're pretty all right right now
well that's the nicest thing you've ever
said to me is orange like a coin yeah
it's like two cents they're just like us
First Watch I have time to go to the
party now
I have time to sneak out so that you
have time to sneak out sing us a song
Yes gear if you go be paradise
alive with your true love
under Royal one
in life
the Raiders are here the rendezviers get
rid of uh the redanians Redondo Beach
dwellers yes
message red
your future husband
oh careful Bud Serenade
serenade no dude yeah leave the door
open
I tried to knock it uh it didn't go well
I think she wants me out of his way fill
up her wishes me to draw you out get
information what do you want yeah well
I've slipped away from my security
detail you're in no danger I promise
that force field that blew you back it
uh last Del Dawn I haven't tried I'm
scared yes
just saying that makes you Brave I think
you know you don't just see people you
see the best in them I'm with this but
I'm also afraid it's a trap keep your
words on eyes
they say keep on playing nice but I have
no desire we're just gonna make out you
learn my song am I playing [__] I did
have anything to you oh yeah buddy
yeah buddy yeah
about damn time
I can't take you inside I'm sorry all
right you could take him inside here
is what they're thinking
oh this is good it's a good thing he's
doing this just who I wanted to see I
mean I asked you to join his search for
cirilla of sintra what is it to you
she is the one who is prophesied
he's using you
what a friend Jilla
seems to be a theme among your allies
could hear why should I trust you you
are smart because it's the only choice
you've got
check for 20 million dollars
this is our first mission
as I lies together
for the White Flame a white flame Flame
that guy's such a [__] her her hubby
yeah he's always right behind her so if
I don't agree with anything that I see
happening and no one listens to me I
have no power here
's your death your demise that Siri
foresaw
dust on her well the chances your book
does too a locator spell could show us
[Music]
holy [__] oh [__]
why was backing Orient is here who uses
Illusions hates me and has a history of
experimenting on young women
it's Strega bore
first without solid proof
will only throw the Mages and the
northern kingdoms into further suspicion
and had no guard the continent in the
process yes but I want to kill him he's
a trade to the Brotherhood
they'll do flowers to him than even you
could let this unfold at the conclave no
one will get to her with the spell I put
on the cabin but if I think it's Strega
bore and they think it's struggabore
then it can't be Strega bore It's gotta
be like tessiah or something we do this
together
are you sure about this not to the
slightest
well I look in gooseberries
now that I can tolerate
you sure about this how are you
damn
dude
look at these two Henry Cavill looks
good they both look amazing
[Music]
The Maccabees
Triumph
tonight I heard they put an aphrodisiac
in the wine they used to my voice
or maybe it's just wine did you see what
Sabrina was wearing by the way she's
older than me yeah
don't compare yourself what is happening
right now I don't know I feel like we're
in a fantasy or something
certainly seems that way
nope there's some good old-fashioned or
romance we just skipped the whole thing
they built to I guess unless it's a
Flash Forward I don't know
[Music]
racist dancing
is it I don't know is this apt
well now we're both races
because they're always just been staring
it's all for us get used to it they'll
be watching us all night I know you
should know the territory before we step
in let's give them a show we have
Sabrina Glover Sig and Marty Sodom
they're passionate lesbians
we have Margarita laurenti current
headmistress and the kiramets and over
by the punches the Plastics
who's grown on me despite my best
efforts of hell
are you expecting me to remember all
those names thank God you asked I
thought you went to oxenford
that's just for us
don't even think about it she's safe and
knocks here until dawn when the ball
ends and the true concave begins a lot
of people in this room are seeing the
exact same thing Jennifer we need this
ball to go off without a hitch so please
there is to stop eating like an underfed
the Google that was inspired by Henry
Cavill trying to get as much from the
catering service on his last season
he's floating up his Witcher packs with
pastries and chips
hmm Carol this is Kerry
school friend of mine yeah
speak your food out
you look hungry
would you like a taste what what do you
think
Witcher do not glamor my man I think Yan
looks particularly lovely this evening
oh he's loyal yeah why did you bring
your pet along
if not for us to uh
do this why don't you go and get a drink
it's a great idea pass around the geralt
I hate when women hit on me yep just the
absolute worst just across the continent
but here in Arizona one would be wise to
abandon neutrality I forget you're
talking to a commoner give us the girl
before it's too late no excuse me
that's why we love them to say I
mentioned they were together as young
majors
first love
never goes away does it you worried
best of luck tomorrow at the conclave
would ya
what are you playing out vilga forts
Stones it's not optional oh hell yeah
it's not optional
oh it's you are you enjoying everything
good she's the one you need uh don't let
her leave your side
I started as a contortionist you know we
can found a new support tomorrow the
diseases that run through this place
yeah seriously I'm here to help I found
trying to predict the accident
uh something bad about to happen
how is Siri
she's safe
[Music]
oh Kiss Me Chris don't worry as long as
geralt and Yen become homecoming king
and queen they'll be fine
oh yeah
or something kind of hot about how Henry
cavill's behave yeah this is a good
secret now man you're with me I know we
got a job tonight but I could think out
it was you
you'll be trying to win Yen back all
evening do you deny it would I deny it
she knows I'm the better man oh yeah
then prove it is this really happening
[Music]
this is really happening I can't tell
what's real in this episode
kick his ass girl kick his ass
[Music]
I promised you and I wouldn't make a
mess this evening
so I won't
too late man
oh [__] whoa
I felt very real although it out
oh it's whatever that trance is in there
yeah these magic wisps
amongst majors of the North
[Music]
they did it
to Sarah and I are optimistic about the
future of this continent based on what
we've seen here tonight and we have
the hell is happening are they gonna
assassinate her or something I don't
know anyone's plotting tonight I could
tell from the moment we entered is that
percussion sound nearest serving fog
then oh rather than murder in a steamed
members
we wait
seek out proof tonight is this this is a
different repeating what happened until
then we have to play nicely if you know
who's going to have any kind of a future
here Voldemort I won't be leaving until
I know she's safe here I hear you
trust me it's like the same but
different very power what a surprise got
Jenny mice tonight
[Laughter]
by the way Marty soda Grand put an
aphrodisiac in that wine hours ago not
to mention the caviar on that plate it's
an illusion
cheap ass Mages
more like it I suffered quite the
greeting from Sabrina Glover Sig earlier
suffered yep such a painful experience
since you've been tracking the Mage so
diligently you must mean Ranch do you
think his master's here tonight good
attempt good
that implies you know trust in what you
see
give you an at least a couple of hours
to piss everyone off trust in what you
see speak of the devil
and she will appear Philippa
headdress made of Satan's Wings bridania
is your only hope of keeping the lion
cubs safe speaking of simpler times to
extreme remember you're talking to a
commoner what is the purpose of this
Choice I'm not sure I'm saving the
continent
rooting out the deadly creatures of
redness Hall not unlike you but you're
one of them I am nothing
I care I want to see just how different
we are pulling all this I feel like he's
just as likely as
anybody but it could be to say of
orchestrating and all she's at the
center of everything as an artifact the
book of monoliths ancient Elven text
that gives a hold of the ability to
travel through time and space Tris and I
trace the book here there's some time
traveling happening right now trackable
has it
you can get him for everything he's done
someone needs to get to his office
undetected
and get the book before he uses it he's
already using it or we are this is cool
I have session Nostalgia for the first
20 minutes of this episode
I never thought we'd come back here
stunts
it's not optional
that percussion sound it could be like
hypnosis or something
[Music]
this was a terrible idea
how is Siri she's safe what someone
could take away what makes her special
powers are innate what if she could have
a chance for a normal life
I don't know what Siri would consider
normal that's a good point we need to
immobilize how create a distraction so
you can slip away oh that's why he
fought with this trip okay so we're just
filling in blanks the signal will be
truce
it's also our safe word geralt I wanted
to apologize Jenna and I had some
important matters
that's what he said you'll be trying to
win Yen back all evening do you deny it
why the [__] would I deny it
prove it unbelievable
yes this is kind of cool it is
I guess
I guess I was a little confusing we
restarted well yeah I was like huh I
felt like something timey why me or
hypnotic was going on but maybe it's
just creative displacement of events
oh
gods
oh damn it punch me
I was wondering how history was able to
land a punch on him and why girl would
do this in the first place
oh my God our time she didn't hear the
truce line
[Music]
I'll take that half breed
ugh seems like a real dinghole your guy
never changes and yet I think there's
leaders forgive and forgive well masses
not mine you've been hard at work
haven't you corrupting portals
kidnapping novices this guy is awful
strikable
has been keeping a list of woven
students the ones who went missing this
month
he's been conducting experiments
practicing mind control what but they're
Elven so does it matter yeah you know
they're not really you know like people
and we believe his ultimate aim is set
on Surah loves
you have proof of this
we do that's right they're in the safe
unless he did something with it
this is the book of monolith
the Pokemon ancient Elven Tom it is the
book of monoliths these are serious
allegations
I propose Dragonborn is held until the
conclave concludes and we can have a
full trial I can come
innocent till proven guilty wait
string of War has been caught though and
he's like owning up to some of this he
was pinned against our own in a time of
unity he's Dragon Ball I kind of stand
by you today maybe it is that guy all
right
keeping make sure it doesn't fall into
the wrong hands again under my bed to
have
should we missing this
I'm just gonna place a bet on all of
them that's how you win at a horse race
to peace
and we have Jennifer
work to thank
you
yes rather and a nearly perfect evening
I love you oh
it's the first time you've ever said
that to anyone they can't be
cheers good answer did we actually put
it off
it's hard to say
I'll get flavor on my head
how would you mean literally tonight
it's like she wanted to be on her side
tell me everything
I care for a stroll alone no no start
from when you guys enter the party yeah
start from when you left yes here
she'd follow her lover anywhere even
blindly towards deaths if he asked it
off her
I wondered if you knew the truth what
happened between to Sayo and I oh we
only grew close to her as the years went
by until the days leading up to the
First Northern wall
she refused and we won at what cost they
held the wire thread until you tapped
into Fire magic
thanks Ian
I saw your fault
afraid Sayer and you stick to this plan
neither of you will be any better off
than poor Lydia
in love with the poison that killed
fast food thank you for coming tonight I
love it means everything so that means
everything to us as well uh-oh
why doesn't that he speak she was
wounded and now she can no longer speak
aloud
only communicate telepathically a woman
with a funny voice
something Terence said yeah
see you just think so much clearer when
you do it I think her earrings are made
of the same thing what were you doing up
there
I went up there after I nearly married
it's trackable
he calmed the waves proving magic need
not be evil or destructive they
conformed what would henceforth be known
as the Brotherhood that day my favorite
piece here
outcasts
I was waiting to deliver this monologue
to you I'd wager we have more in common
than you realize I doubt the parallels
between us are completely parallel
[Laughter]
the stronger the Brotherhood will be
have you
ever been attracted by the art of
sorcery geralt
what is happening join outside in the
battle to come the child will not remain
safe for long your passivity will be no
weapon with which to save her God
everyone's campaigning today let's find
neutrality outrage is everywhere how it
subjects me to offers of packs and
agreements and lectures of a necessity
of making a choice and joining the right
side
so now I shall respond to events and
I'll adapt to the world as it changes
okay
to come
forwards encourages conclave to ensure
peace your guys's abilities to recap
stories is amazing
ly found in the mines in West Virginia
that's where I found those girls locked
in their Castle the first landing it's
that corrupt portal took me when I was
attacked it's Vogue for its favorite
painting he came to say that bracelet
oh my God he's behind it did one of us
guess that last time one of us named him
along with a few others yes yeah it was
an episode four
Joker damn it vilga Ford's I like you
man I'm trying to locate okay if she's
in danger I need to know you don't have
time I'm not leaving her
make sure
oh has the battle begun was can't even
make it to the conclave
damn dick
should have chosen a side would you
damn you're gonna leave us like that
now I have to watch the second half of
this part of the Season show whatever
see
we set it set it in the review
said it wasn't to say uh one of us said
it I don't want care to find it our
patrons know who said it yeah well
probably you is not playing on this
YouTube video
yeah I mean it will probably might have
happened is you might have been like
maybe it's that one guy and I was like
oh vilgaforts and then we were both
pretty convinced at one point that it
was vilga forts because they kept saying
it's straggabore again I was like ass
too much emphasis on the gas too easy
straight or you guessed it and I'm
remembering that and I believed you
regas and I am now taking credit for it
it's one of the two
it feels plausible that either of us
could have guessed it there was a
determined answer that it was him it
just seemed likely yeah
it seemed likely
he's in a fortunate position to be that
guy but I don't care enough to fight for
who's right here I'll go back and look
um
this is my favorite one of the season so
far yeah this was fun this is really
enjoyable I love how there was no action
No Monsters
and it was really engaging the entire
time and it was paced well it felt very
lived in
and uh it was a game of
psychology and chess uh throughout that
I thought was excellent
just watching people knock each other
off the table building to the climatic
reveal
that the guy to Saya is banging is the
baddie
um messed up
yeah damn well uh no that was really
good though uh they played with time and
for an episode that kind of Harkens back
to the party episode of episode four
which was the reveal that we were in a
different timeline remember that and we
were like what this is not confusing
anymore but they revealed that we were
in a different timeline than for this
episode to be revealing uh to be messing
with time and that and then have you
even going I don't know if anything
we're watching is real yeah it was
really confusing at first yeah it
definitely got me in that zone of like
oh what kind of Mind Trick illusion is
going on and then it's not really that
no this is just the perspective episode
it was Vantage Point yeah and I think it
nicely whipped up just yeah that sorted
sense of
paranoid
uh you know converging
campaigns and perspectives and all sorts
of stuff like yeah it nicely like throws
you off your guard into the haze of the
evening and it kind of plays up how
treacherous I would imagine it has to be
to like
you know pull off what are essentially
political Maneuvers but also at a party
where everyone's like hopped up on
aphrodisiac wine and stuff
funny because episode four to a lot of
people is like one of the best episodes
so much so that it's like that's episode
four I I remember I I still recall that
experience like yeah this is the episode
that made me fall in love with the show
was episode four
and it seems like that's where their
strength is at when you put all the
characters
you watch them interact and because
everyone's got their own unique voice
unique dialogue and their own selective
motivations and you're watching everyone
with their own intentions putting it
forward and out in the open and then in
secret as well and trying to form
alliances there's a lot of fun to be had
there so I this is It's a political war
game and I I really like this one a lot
and
you know Henry Cavill was great here
he was so disinterested in the party
itself but there are times where like
the misleads really worked here the
missive good misleads yeah and he was
um really sweet too
can't wait to see Liam Hemsworth's
replacing I know that's what I think so
they can finally reach the full
potential of the show I know when he
said I love you Jennifer I was like oh I
can't wait for them I wish this moment
had been given them I wish the three of
them
the first time we're gonna have to hear
it is gonna be Heavies from Henry Cavill
you know you're not gonna get our first
I love you with the Hemsworth I hate
Liam Hemsworth as a human being everyone
I hate him I blame him I write him hate
mail for all this it's his fault yeah he
wrote the show wrote them and said you
know I think I'd be a better one and
they're like you know what you're right
you know we've been looking for excuse
to kick out old Henry that's what
happened I don't know hey Liam I'll I'll
give him a chance I'll give him a chance
I will I think everyone's gonna give him
a chance for morbid curiosity at least
for one episode Henry Cavill just seems
so Irreplaceable he just slips into this
so well yeah he is he he just it seems
like he really knows you know his take
of the character and just feels right at
home in this world I don't know like you
can really just feel like Henry cavill's
love of witchering through this stuff
even when he's not having to do as much
like witchery stuff and I like I'd be
curious to know how people feel about
this because
this leaned in some ways into like a
romance novel quality that I I loved it
I love that I loved it certainly I liked
having this weird wraparound of like
them in bed after the night's over and
you know kind of having their I just
wanted to be with you all night you know
so in love with her he's so it's got
Temptation flying left and right and he
doesn't give a [__] he's just like no
we're gross get off me her that's what I
want I want Yen her oh like I gave up
internet pornography so I'm not tempted
by you which is
yes you temptresses you you sucky why
sure well and especially because like I
guess the aphrodisiac I I guess he had
the wine eventually it's just like it
still seems to wanna have all these
amazing orgasms that are being offered
my way
this is insanity I'm sure that's every
conversation that happens in an era twos
and party it's just different people
promising different orgasms and
eventually you choose one and you know
see how your luck turns out it made uh
it made geralt very unrelatable that's
what Henry Cavill said I'm leaving the
show he's yeah man I'm a commoner I
wanted yeah yeah where's the common
man's orgy man would be like yes in fact
I will take all of you let's go back to
my room appreciate the offer I'm not
staying at this party so you can do your
own conclave I'm having my own in my
room it is a strange
mid-season finale
because it doesn't end in a way of like
oh [__] gotta watch the next one can't
wait or what it doesn't come out for
like
[Music]
no it doesn't have that at all it's like
if it feels like they were like let's
just stop it here and make everyone wait
yeah yeah yeah I mean I can only stop I
can only understand it in the in the
prediction that the rest of the Epic
what is it three left I think so it's
like three uh so it must be like a huge
battle sequence or you know a couple
episodes like heavily dealing with some
kind of physical con it sounds like
shit's popping off right now so
I would guess that maybe this was all
this sort of political build up to yeah
now the new Sort of hope so Big Bang
finale
because uh because yeah if you look at
what stranger things did that made sense
you know they have this massive reveal
it was like oh damn
and then they had like
two episodes that are equated to like a
full season of television
and and then here it's
yeah I don't know it just doesn't have
that impact oh my God I gotta jog my
memory again three weeks
the first part of the episode when I
still thought it was some kind of weird
Mind Trick illusion I was imagining like
oh this is a cool way like yeah this
would make perfect sense to end the
season off on because I'm sure at the
very end the truth will be revealed and
we'll be like oh [__] there's no traps
they're trapped somewhere yeah yeah or
some reveal like that and then yeah the
way the episode goes like once I got
used to what was happening and how the
perspectives were working I quite
enjoyed it you get to the stuff with
Strega board and you're like okay cool
this bad guy I guess is actually just
gonna be taken taken down or held
accountable for his misdeeds and then
you get like the turnaround of like
realizing vilgaforts but that's
is done in such a like casual Way
Forward yeah it's like with with Strega
bore it's okay that it's straightforward
at first because you're like
well even in the moment I don't know
it's like At first you're like oh well
this okay well we suspected him and uh
and and everyone was right and we took
him down and we're just going back to
the party and so like the thing with
vilgaforcement it didn't feel like a
victory yeah yeah and it's like it has
that dual quality of like yeah we all
knew this dude was a bad guy from like
the very first season and then also we
come back here and like yeah it's good
that he's being taken down that's
clearly something that should have
happened but also it just doesn't feel
like this massive
like I'm a little surprised but at the
same time yeah then you're just like oh
well then he cannot be the source of
like all this big bad trouble and strife
so yeah and then it goes forth and
answers that and then and then like I
get how you leave it off just like oh
man like we thought we were gonna have
this conclave and now there's unrest but
generally speaking just the experience
of watching it yeah it's just sort of
like oh this is very
straightforward transition into a pretty
mellow button like it's it portends you
know Carnage and whatever else and
excitement to come but as like an actual
resting place it feels like we coasted
to a gradual stop here
instead of like you know going out with
a bang or yeah some kind of moment where
you're like [__] I I have to find out
yeah more it's like well I think I know
it's a you know I I expect a battle now
this is gonna be some kind of battle
um and is Siri okay I guess she is uh
Siri's fine yeah skiers getting laid
Yeah and I love Jennifer this season a
lot that's great uh her and geralt I
think are fantastic together
kind of word they're going to kill off
Jennifer let's read the book and find
out let's read the book tonight let's
read the book on camera
they should replace Henry Cavill and
then kill off Jennifer
and then we'll focus on District yes I I
I'll watch the D extra spin-off he's fun
to watch
him and maybe him and geralt are about
to become an unlikely team
I like the rashamoning this episode too
because it's not like a full-on rashaman
but you're just like seeing pieces of a
puzzle scattered about from different
character you're locking into like a
certain character for a little bit and
then hopping around
so it's not like different takes of the
same events but it's like okay you're
shining a flashlight on each corner of
the event and it's kind of neat
say I like the first 20 minutes it'll
kind of like cut to the middle of a
conversation and stuff yeah or was just
like happening so fast uh it was
actually I thought I thought the pacing
that was pretty fun yeah yeah I did too
um
like I didn't feel like I was missing
out on anything so I think that's why I
appreciate it ultimately the time thing
because I'm like you didn't need to do
the time it's it's very much like a
choice it's a gimmick like it doesn't
really it's a device do it it doesn't
lead to this usually you do something
like that to lead to a big reveal yeah
you know yeah but it seemed like it was
all orchestrated around like geralt
finally being like oh you know what I
had this conversation with me
oh [__] I think somebody said this
little tiny thing and we recapped the
whole time when we were doing it and I
completely forgot to leave out this one
conversation he talked about not peace
what's going on there
yeah and the Jewel but they needed to
get the jewelry that's why yeah I don't
know yeah yeah like in the first half of
the episode you're like damn something
crazy is happening and then later on
you're sort of like this is probably a
wise choice to make the distribution of
this information a lot more interesting
because otherwise it would have just
felt like a pretty straightforward
conclusion yeah this part of the season
yeah that's weird it was strange but uh
I I still thought it was it's still my
favorite one of the season for sure yeah
it was really fun one undoubtedly it's
still my favorite one I'd rather get
episodes like this
um
where you get some character substance
to really latch onto and which I know is
not what everyone thinks about the
previous episodes
the fun of watching everybody finally
thrust into the tension of the same room
yeah yeah I'd really love who plays
Jennifer
Anya shalotra no she's great this is
amazing so amazing yeah well in the
comfort that the two of them have
together after so long like really does
it still shines you know oh don't worry
Liam Hemsworth
Apple's gonna leave him this is like a
glowing box of his unique Aura he's
gonna drink it up and it'll be fine I
drink your actress yes
oh maybe they can recast everybody
moving forward oh that'd be even better
yeah get a new Jennifer that'd be great
yeah
Anna Kendrick
Yeah Anna Kendrick and Liam Hemsworth
finally
Pizza I think they have done a movie
together yeah um I'm not sure about who
cares maybe alrighty guys well are you
excited for Anna Kendrick to take over
for the role of Jennifer leave your
thoughts down below what are your
nitpicks that's what we want to know
pick a knit subscribe leave a like hey
let's change your clothes one last time
as we do this patreon
David Gandy if there's anyone I would
like to take to a conclave with me
it would be you man I just I hate social
events honestly in more ways than one if
you ever see me at one guys I'm like
talking to the same like four people all
the time I don't really talk to like a
whole bunch of people sometimes on a
good day you know like ah all right
maybe I'll talk with a little more
people but more often than not I'm in
the mood to get out of there early
um so and so David I want someone to
keep me company the entire time that I
could talk with and hang out with and
that way like uh then I could like you
know gossip about the people who I don't
really want to talk to talk to for like
10 seconds and I'm like yeah
and Dan I feel like you're the perfect
guy because you're more of a listener
than you are a talker so you'd allow me
the opportunity to feel like comfortable
and then like I'm having a good time
socializing tonight because I just be
talking your ear off and you'd just be
listening engaged with that you know
that like cold stare that you gather I'm
like I don't really know if David really
likes what I'm saying right now but I
think he does so that's better David
you'd be the perfect one to go to a
conclave with to judge all the other
people around us while we try to make
everything better in the world so that's
your magic thank you for being you David
I love you with my whole heart we'll
talk soon